In the trailer for Glass, there are a few
scenes that never showed up in the movie.
If you want to see which ones, then stick
around to the end of this video.
Hi, my name is CZ and I created a series called
Things You Missed where I analyse horror movies
based on some of the things that you might have missed.
It's pretty self-explanatory.
As a result of making these episodes, I end
up scrubbing through the trailers a lot to
find footage -- so I ended up noticing that
there were quite a few scenes in the trailers
that weren't actually in the movie.
I decided to look it up and see what info
I could find on this cut content, and ended
up stumbling on an interview titled, M Night
Shyamalan Reveals Why His First Cut Of Glass
Was 3 Hours 20 Minutes.
That's crazy to me.
I mean, to give you a better idea, the final
runtime was 2 hours and 9 minutes.
So over an hour of content was cut.
Not all of that is going to be deleted scenes,
some of it is probably just tightening up
existing scenes and removing a few of the
24 identities of The Horde, but still, that's
a lot of footage left on the cutting room...
recycle bin?
Here's what Shyamalan had to say in the interview.
"Tons of deleted scenes, I think in retrospect
this was the first time I was writing characters
that I already knew, so I could write a lot.
And that's not normal.
Normally I'm finding them as I'm writing.
And the editing process was what is the essence
of what I needed, so there's a lot of deleted
scenes for the Blu-Ray and all that stuff."
With this being our last look into the universe,
the deleted scenes do kind of interest me
just to get one last look at these characters
we've grown to love, but the Blu-Ray won't
be out until April -- so that leaves us with
these scenes that are in the trailers.
Let's take a look at them.
This is the first one, David sitting in this
restaurant.
This woman asks him what he does and he tells
her he's in security.
There's also a slot machine in the corner,
and the TV is broadcasting the opening of
Osaka Tower.
I'd theorize that this was meant to be the
opening scene.
It picks up where David left off in Split,
alone in a diner.
Not literally the same diner, but symbolically
picking up where we left off.
And why it was cut?
If you've seen Unbreakable, you already know
who David is, and we find out about what happened
to his wife in another scene, so showing him
alone again would really just be redundant.
Next, we've got this scene of David in his
rain poncho, throwing someone up on a wall.
It looks like he's in some sort of tunnel
and from what I can tell, he's protecting
a woman who's been attacked by this criminal;
I think this is a purse right here.
This probably takes place before the face-off
with The Beast at the factory, and again,
we already get a good idea of David's life
of vigilante justice in this other scene,
this scene may not have been needed.
I do like the symbolic shot composition though,
with the wall colors being yellow and purple,
the colors of The Horde and Mr. Glass, and
this fence in the foreground telling us that
David is going to be locked in with these two
enemies.
In fact it even has the same pattern as the
window on the door to Mr. Glass's room.
This next one takes place in the final battle
sequence -- it would seem that there's a moment
where Joseph's wrist is injured at some point.
It looks like this might be after Casey goes
to try to get Kevin to come into the light,
because she's not there on the steps with
them.
So there may have been a beat where the Beast
hurts Joseph.
I also wouldn't be surprised if the Black
Clover Society was responsible.
I also have to wonder if part of that hour
of cut content was Joseph questioning if the
super powers were somehow hereditary... no,
not that Hereditary, and he tries to do something
that only his father would have been able
to do.
Perhaps the most mysterious of the deleted
scenes though, is this, where The Beast is
clutching this woman's head.
It doesn't appear to be in a violent way though.
My first thought was that this is Dr. Staple,
but the outfit doesn't seem to match what
she was wearing after Mr. Glass broke The
Horde out of his room.
My theory is that there was a scene where
they run into another patient at the institution
and The Beast, for the same reasons that he
let Casey go at the end of Split, lets her
go, because he sees that she is broken and
therefore pure.
We also get a better look at this during
the final trailer, and see that there are
many people, possibly patients of Raven Hill,
that are reaching out to The Beast in some
kind of therapeutic ritual.
There's nothing similar to that in the movie,
so I'd be interested to potentially find out
what that was going on there.
Let me know what your theories are about what
was left out the movie, and anything you may
have noticed from the trailers that didn't
make the cut.
I'll also be covering the deleted scenes on
Things You Missed when they are released,
so make sure you're subscribed to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week, ring that deathbell
for notifications and I'll see you in the
next one.
Assuming, we both survive.